So with team building,
you know you have it right.
And it's an incredible moment when all
of a sudden your team does something
that you could have never thought of and
better than you could have ever done it.
And that's why you do it.
The reason you bring
people into your company.
And bring them into your vision, is
because they're going to make it better
than it ever was inside your head.
And those moments,
there'll be these moments where you
just notice that something will happen,
and you'll be, I had nothing to do
with that and it was extraordinary.
And those are just, that's honestly for
me, that's why I love
starting companies.